مدرعات ودفاعات جويه وصواريخ مضاده للدروع
مساعدات امريكيه جديده لاوكرانيا يعلنها
البنتاجون
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في الكونغرس
يقول ان ايران تحتقر القوانين الدوليه عبر
مد الحوثيين بالاسلحه
ماكرون ويصر على تعديلته القانونيه
ونقابات العمال لتتوعده بمزيد من
الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
الاخبار المفصله من العربيه انا ميسون
عزام احييكم اسعد الله صباحكم اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون اعلنت عن حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه تصل
الى 2.5 مليار دولار اعطت التفويض بسحب
المعدات العسكريه من مخزونات وزاره الدفاع
وارسالها لاوكرانيا الحزمه الجديده تشمل
ذخائر لصواريخ ارض جو متقدمه بالاضافه الى
ثمانيه انظمه دفاع جوي من طراز افنجر كما
تشمل تسعا 59
مركبه برادلي قتاليه 500 و90 صاروخ تاو
المضاد الدبابات ومئات الالاف من الذخائر
ضمت الحزمه ايضا 90 ناقله افراد مصفحه من
طراز سترايكر 20 مع كاسه حتى انغام
بالاضافه الى 20,000 طلقه مدفعيه من عيار
155 متر وقرابه ال 600 تلقى مدفعيه
الدقيقه التوجيه
وخمسه وتسعين الف قذيفه مدفعيه من عيار
150 ملم الحزمه ضمت ايضا عربات دعم
ومركبات قياده ومركبات تكتيكيه لسحب
الاسلحه وصواريخ مضاده للدروع وملايين
الطلاقات من ذخائر الاسلحه الصغيره في
المجموع التزمت الولايات المتحده باكثر من
27 مليار دولار كمساعدات عسكريه وامنيه
لاوكرانيا منذ بدايه
هذا وقد بحث مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جزء بوريل بحث في اتصالا
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الانترنت
الملف الايراني ودعم اوكرانيا اكد بوراي
العزم الاتحاد الاوروبي على مواصله تقديمه
دعم حقيقيه لاوكرانيا بما في ذلك الدعم
العسكري مضيفا انه ناقش مع بلنك الموضوع
ايران وغرب البلقان والصين
التطورات المتسارعه في مسار الحرب
الاوكرانيه باتت تعكس بما لا يضع مجالا
للشك بان الامور تتجه نحو التصعيد جميع
الاطراف ترجح بان الايام المقبله ستشكل
منعطفا حاسما في الحرب والتلويح بمرحله
جديده لا تستبعد السلاح النووي فعلى
الجانب الروسي التصريحات في جلها تصب في
خانه التحذير والتهديد على الجانب
الاوكراني لا تتوقف الدعوات بتسريع
التسريح لحسم المعركه اما الموقف اللافت
فجاء من الغرب هذه المره من خلال حزمه
الدعم عسكري غير مسبوقه لاوكرانيا فيما
توقع الرئيس الاوكراني المزيد من التسليح
من الحلفاء
من ذوي المدافع هذا الى نيران التحذير
والوعيد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي حظر الغرب من مساعد تسليح اوكرانيا
باسلحه ثقيله وانظمه هجوميه
متواعدا بان خساره قوه النوويه مثل روسيا
في حرب تقليديه ستؤدي الى اندلاع حرب
النوويه تحذير عززه الكرملين واكد
بالاضافه ان تحضيرات ميت بدر من الحرب
النوويه تتوافق تماما مع العقيده النوويه
الروسيه
يتزامن ذلك مع تحولات جذريه
حيث تدرس اداره الرئيس الامريكي
رساله
لمساعدتها في ضرب شبه جزيره القرم التي
ضمتها روسيا عام 2014 وفقا يورك تايمز
الصحيفه اضافت انه بعد اشهر من المناقشات
مع ودينا الاوكرانيين بدات اداره بيض
اخيره لاعتراف بانكيف قد تحتاج الى القوه
لضرب هذا الملاذ الروسي حتى لو كانت هذه
الخطوه ستزيد من خطر التصعيد القرم
الواقعه بين البحر الاسود وبحر ازوب موطن
لعشرات الالاف من الجنود الروس روسيا
تعتمد الى حد كبير على قواعدها العسكريه
في شبه جزيره القرم في شن هجمات مكنتها من
الاستيلاء على الاراضي جنوبيه اوكرانيا
العام الماضي
الولايات المتحده اصرت ولسنوات على ان
القرن لا تزال جزءا من اوكرانيا
وبحرنا وجبالنا اعطونا اسلحتكم سنستعيد
ارضنا
جزيره القرم تعود لواجهه الاحداث من جديد
مسار اخر تدخله الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
مع سعي كل طرف للسيطره على كامل اراضي شبه
جزيره القرم
شه
ستظل تشكل تهديدا للحلف حتى لو هزمت
قواتها في اوكرانيا
الاميرال روبور قال وهو رئيس اللجنه
العسكريه للحلف قال مهما كانت النتيجه
نتيجه هذه الحرب من المرشح ان تكون للروس
طموحات مماثله فبالتالي فان التهديد لا
يزور الاضافه باور انه في الوقت الذي
تستنفذ فيه او تستنفذ فيه الحرب قوه روسيا
وعتادها وداخلتها فان دول الحلف تتوقع ان
تحاول موسكو اعاده بناء قدراته العسكريه
وتعزيز هذه القدرات
بلده الكسندروفا الواقعه بين مدينتين
دونيت مارينكا شمال مقاطع الدونات تعتبر
مركزا للجنود الروسي الذين يقاتلون في
المحور الشمالي الغربي من الاقليم وتعتبر
من اكثر المناطق التي تشهد سقوط قذائف
للجيش الاوكراني وكذلك طبعا نيران الجيش
الروسي زميلنا رائد الاخبار عد لنا هذا
التقرير
وضواحيها توجهنا الى بلده الكسندرا التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي شمال غربي
المقاطعه ما زالت البلده تتعرض لقصف عنيف
وبقي فيها قليل من السكر
المتاخمه لمدينه مارينكا حيث المعارك
الساخنه المستمره حيث يستمر الجيش الروسي
بمواصله اعماله العسكريه رغم سقوط القذائف
والصواريخ على مناطق المدنيه تتيانا تعاني
من اعاقه بساقها حدثتنا عن معاناتها بعد
تعرض بيتها للقذف واستغيها بزوجها
سقطت في المنزل
مباشره
الى انعدام الغاز
ذلك ما جعل مدفاه الحطب صانعه الدفء
والطعام والضوء في هذا المكان
في العصر الحجري وانا احضر الطعام من لا
شيء على الحطب هذه الاواني مثقوبه من
شظايا الصاروخ
الروسي ونقطه انطلاقه لمواجهه الجيش
الاوكراني في مدينه
القوات الاوكرانيه
لنسمع من الجنود عن احوال المعارك في هذه
المنطقه الدستور
حتى الان
من هذا المكان وعلى بعد عشرات الامطار ما
زالت الاله العسكريه هي تقصف بالمدافع
وراجمات الصواريخ مواقع الجيش الاوكراني
التي ما زالت تتمركز في اخر المدينه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
اواخر معرينكا مقاطعه الدانيت
قررت روسيا ارسال الروبوت الروسي القتالي
ماركر الى منطقه التماس فى الدمشقيه
اوكرانيا خلال الفتره الماضيه الرابط
ماركر يتمتع بنظام تحكم الي كما يستطيع
تحديد اهداف العدو من مسافه 15 كيلو متر
متابعه
[موسيقى]
لقي الرجل الذي يكرم لانه انقذ كليب دينيس
كاريف مصيرا ماساويا اذا قتل على يد شعبه
مكافحه التجسس بشبهه الخيانه في وسط
العاصمه كيف واستريت جورنال نقلت مزيدا من
تفاصيل حول هذه القصه الجديده
[موسيقى]
برصاصه في الجمجمه ملقاه على رصيف وسط
العاصمه كياب
القتيل لم يكن مواطنا الاوكرانيا عاديا
مقتله اثار جدلا واسعا فهل دينيس كريب
جاسوس الروسي ان بطل تساؤلات لصحيفه وستري
جورنال اجاب عليها مسؤولون حكوميون
واستخباراتين اوكرا دينيس مصرفي وضابط
مخابرات انضم لمفاوضات السلام في 28 من
فبراير في بيلاروسيا في دور غير محدد الا
ان حضوره كان بطلب من الجانبين عده روايات
ومراسم دفن غير اعتياديه فمسول جهاز الامن
الاوكراني قال حينها ان دينيس كريف قتل
بصفته خائنه لتجسسه لصالح موسكو لكن بعد
ايام من القائل جثتي كريف الذي وصف
بالجاسوس وقتل على اساس ذلك دفن بطلا
بجوار اول وزير خارجيه لاوكرانيا ووقع
الرئيس الاوكراني اوراقه لمنحه وساما
لواجبه الاستثنائي في الدفاع عن سياده
الدوله
تقديرا لجهوده في الحيلوله دون تقدم
القوات الروسيه نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه
فبراير العام الماضي بفضل معلومات بغايه
الدقه نقلها كريف من اتصالاته مع الروس
دورا الداهو الدينس كريم لم تنكره الجهات
الرسميه الا ان وفاته دفعت موسكو وكياف
للتحفظ على التعليق دفن مع مرتبه الشرف
العسكريه ومعه سره الا انه على مدى اشهر
ثلاث مقتله فتحت اوكرانيا اكثر من 650
قضيه خيانه تورط فيها مسؤولون حكوميون
روان حمزه العربيه
اعلنت جنوب افريقيا انها ستجري منورات
بحريه عسكريه مشتركه مع روسيا والصين
الشهر المقبل تستمر 10 ايام وقال بيان
الصادر عن الجيش ان هذه المناورات هي
الثانيه من نوعها لقوات الدول الثلاث وان
اكثر من 350 من افراد جيش جنوب افريقيا
سيشاركون نظرائهم الروس والصينيين بهدف
تبادل المهاره
قال رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي بوب مندس ان انتهاكات
ايران المتكرره لحضر الاسلحه التي تفرضه
الامم المتحده ضد الحوثيين يظهر تجاهلها
التاريخ للقانون الدولي في الداخل والخارج
وعبر عن امتنانه لقيام البحريه الامريكيه
باعتراض شحنه اسلحه يعتقد انها كانت في
طريقها من ايران لجماعه الحوثي اليمنيه
مضيفا ان هذه الشحنه من الاسلحه لو تم
تسليمها للحوثيين كانت تضر بالشعب اليمني
وتقود وقفه اطلاق النار في اليمن
افادت مصادر الدبلوماسيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان الاتحاد سيضيف 37 كيان جديدا
الاثنين المقبل العقوبات المفروضه على
ايران من جهته صوت البرلمان الاوروبي في
اجتماعه الخميس لصالح قرار يدعو الى تصنيف
الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه كما صوت ايضا
لادراج المرشد علي خامئي والرئيس ابراهيم
الرئيسي اضافه الى المدعي العام الايراني
محمد منتظر على قوائم العقوبات البرلمان
الاوروبي طلب ايضا باحاله ملف انتهاكات
حقوق الانسان في ايران الى مجلس الامن
ودنا الاتحاد وبشده اعمال التعذيب والعنف
وانتزاع الاعترافات بالقوه في السجون
الايرانيه
في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد
منح الفلسطينيين دولتهم شرط لاقامه علاقات
دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل
اهلا بكم مجددا قال وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان الاتفاق
على اقامه دوله فلسطينيه سيكون شرطا مسبقا
لاقامه على قناه دبلوماسيه رسميه مع
اسرائيل قال الامير فيصل بن فرحان في
مقابله مع تلفزيون
قال ان الاستقرار الحقيقي في المنطقه لا
يتحقق الا من خلال اعطاء الامل
للفلسطينيين مشيرا الى ان ذلك ياتي من
خلال فلسطينيين دولتها وفي سياق اخر قال
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه انه يجب العمل
للوصول الى حل سياسي للازمه السوريه مشيرا
الى انه يتم التعاون مع الشركاء لاكتشاف
في طريقه للتعامل مع الحكومه في دمشق كما
اشار الى ان الولايات المتحده تعد الشريك
الامن الاكثر نشاطا في المنطقه
التجاري مهم للمملكه
اجرى مستشار الامن القومي الامريكيه
لقاءات مع صانعي القرار في اسرائيل انصبت
على الملف الايراني وعلى الوضع الفلسطيني
والوضع الاقليمي كما زار المسؤول الامريكي
للاراضي الفلسطينيه في رساله بان اداره لن
تتقبل التوجه لدى عدد من وزراء نتنياهو
المتطرفين
وحكومه نتنياهو اليمنيه بمركباتها
المتطرفه غير المقبوله على الامريكيين حول
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي في اول
لقاءات رسميه مع اركانها التشديد على
ضروره استمرار التنسيق حول مواجهه ايران
وتجنب المفاجاه هات ولا جيم سياسه
الاستيطان ومنع انفجار الوضع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه فيما اوضح نتنياهو ان اولويته
تبقى منع ايران نوويه ورفض العوده الاتفاق
معها
من خلال العمل المشترك مع ان يمكننا
مواجهه التحديات واستغلال الفرص ما يقوي
التحالف بيننا والجهد المشترك لوقف برنامج
ايران النووي
نقول تحياتي الرئيس ايضا الملتزم بعمق
باني اسرائيل وامريكا ملتزمه باسرائيل
التزام فيه مبادئ مشتركه ونعمل بشكل مشترك
لمواجهه التحديات والفرس
سوليبان التقى وزيري الدفاع والخارجيه
الاسرائيليين والرئيس الاسرائيلي كما زعيم
المعارضه ايضا وليس من باب المصادفه ان
يطلب الامريكيون من اسرائيل تجميد خطه
استراليا في القدس الشرقيه المحتله
بالتزامن مع زياره سوليفان وان تشمل
الزياره شقا فلسطينيه في محاوله للربط ما
بين حاجه اسرائيل في الملف الايراني ورغبه
واشنطن في عدم تدمير حل الدولتين على
الارض تمام تماما
عليها ان تعمل على وقف كافه الاجراءات
احاديث الجانب من الجانب الاسرائيلي وااا
من اجل فعلا ان همم نتمكن من
ايجاد نوع من الهدوء والاستقرار في الارض
الفلسطينيه المحتله في رام الله التقى
سليبان الرئيس الفلسطيني ومدير المخابرات
وسمع تحذيرا فلسطينيه من انفجار الوضع
الميداني وانهاء الحل السياسي ومطالبه
بالوفاء بتعهد الاداره الامريكيه باعاده
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه
المحتله زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
تظهر ملايين الفرنسيين اليوم احتجاجا على
رفع الحكومه سنه التقاعد والغلاء الاسعار
التظاهرات عامه كل المدن الفرنسيه واكبرها
كانت في باريس حيث احصل اكثر من 400 الف
متظاهر وفقا للمنظمين
على رفع سن التقاعد هذه الموجه هي الاولى
من ثلاث موجات ستكون الثانيه
في السادس من شهر فبراير وستمر
لثلاثه ايام هذا التحرك كان وليد اتفاقا
بين ثمان نقابات عماليه دعمته جبهه يساريه
موحد ضمت كل الاحزاب وتواجد ممثلها في
الشارع ما جعل صوره تظاهرات استثنائيه
ونادره واعترفت الشرطه بانها مليونيه
ان يحصل اطفال على التقاعد نفسه الذي حصلت
عليه
وكما جرت العاده سرعان ما تحولت الشوارع
الى ساحه مواجهه عندما حاولت الشرطه تقسيم
الموكب الضخم الى مواكب يسهل تفريقها
محاوله اثارت غضب مجموعات شبابيه فرقتها
الشرطه بالغاز المسيء للدموع وباعتقال بعض
افرادها واصابه اخرين نقل بعضهم الى الحجز
رغم اصاباتهم
اصحاب الدخل المحدود يعيشون حياه صعبه
باسم هذا غير عادل ولهذا السبب انا هنا
اليوم
الفرنسيين في الشارع حكومته لاخذ خطوه الى
الوراء ذلك فعلته حكومه جاك شيراك عام
1995 عندما فكر الرئيس الراحل برفع سن
التقاعد لكن الحكومه الحاليه اعلنت مسبقا
انها لن راجع
فادي دهوك العربيه باريس
في هذه الاصلاحات التي لا تحظى كما نلاحظ
بشعبيه في فرنسا رئيس فرنسا اشار الى ان
الحكومه الفرنسيه ستنفذ الامر باحترام
وبروح من الحوار الى جانب الحزم
والمسؤوليه
بمناسبه مرور عامين على تسلم جوبا ايضا
الرئاسه الامريكيه ابرز المحطات في
السياسه الداخليه والخارجيه لاداراته
وابرز مستحقات التي تنتظره في العامين
المقبلين متابعه
مضى عماني على رئاسه تشوبايدن للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمؤشر الاهم على فشله
او نجاحه هو استطلاعات الراي
تشير الى
55% من الامريكيين يعارضون سياسات الرئيس
الامريكي علما انه قدم لهم بعض الانجازات
فهو واجه التضخم الذي وصل الى اكثر من 10%
وتمكن من تخطي الازمه من دون الدخول في
ازمه اقتصاديه اوليه كما انه اظهر الى
الامريكيين انه يهتم بهم من خلال الجايحه
لكن الالاف ماتوا في عهده
[موسيقى]
انت غبيا حقق مع الحزب الديمقراطي انتصارا
في الانتخابات النصفيه عند محتفظوا بمجلس
الشيوخ
في ما انتزع الجمهريون مجلس النواب
وسيستعملونه لمحاسبته مشاكل بيضا فضيحه
الوثائق السريه التي اكتشفها المحامون في
مكتبه وبيته وهى تعادل فضيحه وثائق الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب لكننا لم نرى بعد
تاثير هذه القضيه على شعبيه بيضه
اما في عشان الخارجي فاسرع بيضا للانسحاب
من افغانستان
بقيت صادمه للراي العام
دوليا ايضا دعم ايضا بالسلاح والمال
اوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا لكنه النجاح في
ابقاء الجنود الامريكيين خارج المعركه
وتحاشا مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا
الانجاز والاهم لدى بيدن خلال العامين وهو
ترميم العلاقات الامريكيه مع المجموعات
الدوليه بدءا من الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
ويعمل الان على ترميم العلاقات مع افريقيا
وينظم مواجهه الصين اقتصاديا وعسكريا
بالتعاون مع استراليا واليابان والهند فشل
حتى الان في العوده الى الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران واعاد مبدا حل الدولتين لحل الصراع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني وما زال في الخطوات
الاولى
هناك صوره ثانيه للرئيس بيضا الصوره
الاولى هي صوره رئيس اكبر دوله في العالم
اقتصاديا وعسكريا وسوره الرئيس المتلعثم
في الكلام
اذا ما كان سيترشح في مواجهه دونالد ترامب
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
الى اخبار الرياضه
بعد فوزه على فريق نجوم الهلال والنصر
الملك فهد الدولي
نانا منتخب العراق لقب كاس الخليج العربي
لكره القدم بفوزه في المباراه النهائيه
على منتخب سلطنه عمان بثلاثه اهداف
الاثنين
تقدم فريق الاتحاد الى صداره الدوري
السعودي بفوز على ضيفه الفيحاء بثلاثه
اهداف دون رد في الجوله الرابعه عشر
للمسابقه
وتعادل فريق العداله مع ضيفه الباطن بهدف
لكل منهما بالدوري السعودي
وتتواصل اليوم احداث الجوله الرابعه عشر
من الدوري السعودي باقامه ثلاث مباريات
حيث يحل الشباب ضيفا على التعاون ويستقبل
الخليج ضيفه الرائد ويرتحل الفتح لمواجهه
ضمك
وصواريخ مضاده للدروع مساعده امريكيه
جديده لاوكرانيا يعلنها البنتاجون
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في الكونجرس
يقول ان ايران تحتقر القوانين الدوليه عبر
مد الحوثيين بالاسلحه
على تعديلاته القانونيه
ونقابات العمال تتوعده بمزيد من
الاحتجاجات
النشره انتهت نلتقي بعد دقائق من الان
ونشر مفصله جديده مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]